- Drew Carey is here!
- Hi, everybody.
(audience applauds)
- The Price is Right's 9,000th episode,
which airs tomorrow on CBS.
As part of the festivities,
Candice, who won earlier
to come on down with us and hang out,
and Theresa is over there
getting ready to model for us.
Are you excited, Theresa?
- Beyond.
- [Kelly] All right.
- Oh, everybody knows that if
I didn't talk to dead people
that I wanted to be a Barker Beauty.
But I guess I will be your Drew Doll,
how's that?
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Drew] Oh, we'll just
call it what it is.
- A Drew Doll, I like a Drew Doll.
Okay, now let's find out
what Candice is playing for.
- It's a cruise on Norwegian Cruise Line!
(audience applauds)
- [Candice] All right, looks wonderful.
- It's a nice cruise on a
Norwegian Cruise Line, right?
So we're playing a game called Secret X.
There's an X hidden behind
one of the question marks.
Could be the top, could be in the middle,
could be at the bottom, we don't know,
that's for you to figure out.
I'm gonna give you one free X.
Here's your free X.
- Thank you.
- Velcro that anywhere,
in any yellow square.
Any yellow square, just put
it in any yellow square,
like you were playing Tic Tac Toe.
- Oh my god, you are so,
you just did it!
- Perfect spot.
- Already.
- There was no...
She said, "Oh, I'm ready."
- I have two more Xs for you.
(audience laughs)
- [Theresa] Uh oh!
- I would've debated.
- I would, I'm already nervous.
- But you can only get an X
if you know the price of the
heated mug or the panini press.
Is it $80 or $120?
- Drew, I'm going to say that's $120.
- Are you sure?
- [Kelly] We were gonna say 80.
- Are you sure that's
all the way up to $120?
(crowd shouts)
- [Chloe] 80, it's 80, it's 80, it's 80.
- I'm gonna change my answer Drew: $80.
- $80, is it $80?
(audience applauds)
- [Drew] Yes,
- [Candice] Yes!
- [Drew] It's $80.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, we were close!
- [Drew] Put your X anywhere
you want, anywhere you want.
- I can put it on the question mark?
- No, you put it on any
yellow spot you want.
- I mean take it, I mean take a minute.
You are very just "Yes."
- The X is in the top, middle, or bottom.
- It's a Norwegian Cruise.
- Any yellow spot you want.
- Let's go.
- That's no small thing.
- [Drew] Perfect.
- [Chloe] Yeah!
- All right, all right, all right.
- Okay one more X.
Is the panini press $23 or $40?
- I'm going to go with $23.
- Are you sure?
Whoa, wait, stop!
- [Chloe] That was, oh--
- I'm going to change my answer.
The panini press is $40.
- [Kelly] I would say 40.
- [Drew] Is it $40?
- [Kelly] I would say 40, I would say 40.
- It is $40!
You've got another one.
- I guessed that one, I guessed that one.
- [Drew] Anywhere you want.
- This is an exciting game.
- [Kelly] Oh my god I'm gonna--
- [Candice] Is this my last X?
- That's your last X.
- [Candice] But I can put
it on the question mark?
- No, you can't put it
on the questions mark.
That's where the Xs are hidden.
Put it on one of the yellow spots.
- [Kelly] The X is
somewhere in here, yeah.
- [Candice] Okay.
- Okay.
- She is so decisive!
- You see this right here?
When I say three, hit that.
If you get Tic Tac Toe, you're
going on a Norwegian cruise,
on a Norwegian Cruise Line.
So we go one, two--
- God, I'm so nervous.
- Three, hit the button!
And you're a winner!
(everyone cheers)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- Nice job.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Candice] Thank you!
- [Drew] That's all there is to it.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
(audience cheers)
- [Drew] An amazing
Norwegian Cruise Line cruise.
Congratulations.
- [Kelly] I wanna go on a cruise.